hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 6
Jonah Hex video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet so
Canadian a hex episode but just a
reminder this is the last episode before
the big 4 night crossover so there's no
episode next week but the week after
that in two weeks is when episode 7 is
going to drop that's called invasion
it's like the last night of the big four
night crossover so I'll just remind
everyone what the schedule is for next
week at the end of this video but this
was mostly meant to be a Jonah Hex Wild
West episode Great Train Robbery great
saloon brawl you can't have a Western
without like a really awesome saloon
brawl so let's do top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs and I'll try to like
explain stuff that's going to lead into
the big four and I cross over to so
number 10 Geoff ah he rolls into town if
you don't know who he is he's been on a
whole bunch of genre TV he's like this
really big b-movie name so most people
just know him from loss but he did a
lawnmower man he did all these crazy
sci-fi B movies so anytime he shows up
you know it's gonna be nuts
number 9 though the dwarf star alloy so
like the minute they said that there was
some really special or and we knew that
Adam was gonna get his suit back I was
like okay this is probably the dwarf
star alloy so that he can rebuild it but
Turnbull kills the time traveller takes
his technology so that he learns that
it's really special and uses it as an
explosive device he cooks his bullets
with it which kind of reminds you of the
Judas bullets from Luke Cage just
basically like really badass bullets
that can penetrate citizen steel skin so
number eight though there is enough
dwarf star alloy left at the end of the
episode for Adam to power 20 Adam suits
now that doesn't mean that he's gonna
build 20 Adam suits it just means that
he has a lot of extra power to spare so
he's probably gonna do something really
cool after he builds another atom suit
but number seven he does build citizen
Steel's comic book costume for him so
he'll wear that like you can see like
some of the arms and the face are
exposed so that when he does go full
steel he'll look a little closer to his
comic book self but you guys can let me
know what you think of the design I
think it's okay but we have to see him
in
like in action to get a sense for it
it's kind of hard to tell just looking
at it right here but for those are you
asking about the new atom suit I don't
know how much they're gonna change it
from the old one it looks pretty close
but I think that they're gonna use the
opportunity to make it a little bit
cooler maybe give it some more powers
like he said he has a bunch of dwarf
star alloy to spare so he'll probably
build some cool weapons and technology
with that but number six they know about
the speedster who's working with damian
darhk-- they don't know exactly who you
Bart dawn is or the reverse-flash his
history with Barry so they're like okay
we're gonna have to do some more
research you you know firestorm go find
out all you can about speedsters in
coincidence they're the ones that heard
that secret message from Barry so that's
just gonna play into the legion of
Doom's storyline so this is like the TV
shows Way of telling you that that's
something that's going to be followed up
on in later episodes like they're not
gonna figure it out right away along
with the talisman that the reverse-flash
wanted damian darhk-- to steal like
citizens steal is gonna have to do a lot
of research to figure out what it does
but it's not gonna happen right away and
I don't know if it's gonna have anything
to do with the four-night crossover
because that's purely Dominator stuff
that's not really Legion of Doom
but number 5 Martin Stein's brain quakes
I do think that is something that they
will answer like a big question about
that in the four night crossover but he
was right when he said that he
interacted with his past self and that
created some different time line and
that's what he's experiencing right now
but as weird as that seems I do think
that they will answer that question
during the four night crossover number
four welcome back Jonah Hex they save
him from being hung by Turnbull's men
he's trying to get the bounty on turn
Bulls head they drop a whole bunch of
references to stuff that we learned last
year in the Jonah Hex episode if he
didn't watch season 1 of legends of
tomorrow they did a Jonah Hex episode
where they teased the secret history
between rip hunter and Jonah Hex like
rip hunter longtime time traveler had
had previous adventures with Jonah Hex
so when they were talking about the big
Turnbull event like the big battle that
rip hunter left that was something that
happened pre season 1 so like the
legends weren't part of that that was
like a rip hunter Jonah Hex thing but as
their way of letting you know that Jonah
Hex has a lot of history with the
Turnbull character so that's why he
wants to bring him in so bad but it was
pretty badass seeing citizens still eat
that bullet with his teeth so number
three citizen Steele stops the train
with his powers what they're trying to
do most of you probably picked up on
this it just give you a sense for what
his power level is like what he can do
what he can't do he's not invulnerable
like he eats the bullet there aren't
things that can penetrate his skin but
he is strong enough to stop a moving
train but he probably couldn't do that
all day long like he is probably really
hurting inside after he did that so what
I'm really hoping for is that like the
next big test is is that they'll have
the reverse-flash try to phase his hand
through his skin we'll see if he can but
he should be able to do it if dwarf star
alloy can penetrate his skin in the
reverse-flash is so fast that he can
time-travel then he can probably vibrate
his hand through citizen steel but
number 2 vixen and heatwave team-up this
was a really awesome heat wave episode
but I love the energy that he has with
vixens character she tells him she knows
all about animals
now heatwave does not know about how her
totems work he doesn't know that her
powers literally flow from the animals
of the earth so it's kind of a funny
moment too but it's really touching and
they're just letting you know that
they're gonna continue their friendship
she's gonna help train him mentally more
than physically like just help him
Center himself a little bit but even
though he's gonna be doing heroic things
that doesn't mean that he's gonna be a
hero by the end of the season he's still
gonna be you know very ambiguous he's
meant to be complicated they've done a
much better job of writing his character
this season in this version of vixen is
really awesome too so I just really love
the two of them together and of course
number one WTF is our friends in 2016
need our help
that's the teaser for the four night
crossover so the schedule is a little
out of whack so just to explain that
real quick next week there'll be new
episodes of Supergirl and flash but
everything else is on break so no arrow
no legends of tomorrow then the week
after that starting on Monday November
28th Supergirl is the first night of the
crossover and then each night thereafter
is like the next night so the week of
the 28th it's Supergirl flash
legends of tomorrow it'll be super crazy
and even though they have like the big
dominators invasion storyline from the
comics going on they'll each have like
their own specific storyline happening
for Supergirl for flash for arrow for
the legends within each of their own
episodes so like arrows getting its
hundredth episode they're not gonna
completely hijack that in all the arrow
stuff that they could be doing just for
the dominator storyline it'll all work
together don't worry just be sure to
watch each episode of each of the shows
that week of the crossover if you
haven't been watching all the shows this
season so during that week like even
though I haven't been doing Supergirl
videos for every episode I will do like
a Supergirl video I'll do flash arrow
legends of tomorrow so don't worry I'll
be doing videos for all that stuff
there'll be some more trailers for that
so it's gonna be crazy but let me know
what did you guys think of Jonah Hex in
this episode and what do you think of
citizen Steel's costume I think it'll
get a little bit cooler season 2 season
depending on who comes back for legend
season 3 but speaking of the schedule I
almost forgot so they made this huge
change to legends of tomorrow in the
second half of the season this year so
for season 2 what's gonna happen when
they come back in the spring is that
it's going to be on Tuesday nights after
the flash at 9 p.m. so you'll have flash
then legends of tomorrow and then on
Wednesdays they'll be arrow so that
means that there'll be no DC TV stuff
happening on Thursdays anymore it'll be
Monday Tuesday Wednesday for everything
so I will say congratulations to GI Jack
you're the DC giveaway winner this week
is a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details so there'll be plenty more DC
Marvel in the next couple of days so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll probably do a couple of comic book
videos this weekend - will you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
the trailer for the big four night
crossover and you can click here for the
killer frost flash trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight